in this high-security lab a team of
experts is tasting a lot of booze we're
kind of a combination of mixologist
meets scientists they work for Diageo
the world's largest spirits maker and
they're searching for the next hit
alcohol flavor what if you guys been
working on recently
everything from whiskey to vodkas to
rums at any one time we can be working
on 50 different ideas in this lab our
consumers are constantly interested in
new ideas in order to really grab a
consumers attention you need to put
something out there that really doesn't
look like everything else out there the
way this idea to make it from the lab to
the shelf
Captain Morgan 1671 it's a limited
edition premium rum finished in Spanish
oak bringing a project like this to
fruition can be a six to nine month
process and it usually starts with
market research a lot of the marketing
team in my team has spent a lot of time
at bars to really kind of identify
what's the trends what are consumers
really responded to we're seeing a
little bit of movement into kind of more
savory flavors dried notes spices woods
next it's up to the team of liquid
developers to come up with a new
flavored alcohol that plays into those
trends
starting with base alcohols they spice
up the drink from a flavor library of
thousands of extracts ok so I like
applewood smoked vanilla that is gonna
be really - cheers Cheers
I think that's delicious I have bad with
the gold standard recipe in place the
product goes into mass production some
products like captain 1671 our planet
limited releases to take advantage of
hot flavor trends and keep customers
engaged with the brand at the end the
consumer really decides whether these
things are going to be successful enough
there's a difference between a flavour
of the month
and the one that they want to enjoy for
years and years